what is this one strawberry field Monica
that strawberries on sushi a barber very
Japanese chef in America I'd like to
apologize it's very weird
what part of so you wouldn't cover white
tuna with strawberries and then glaze it
strawberry fields rather [ __ ] ear
beetle now for the lamb with Roberts
ridiculous $15 extra charge its rack of
lamb and crusted in macadamia nuts fresh
herbs and a little bit of Dijon mustard
it's served with a honey vinegar
reduction I even cooked properly I was
getting nervous when you see white fat
like that on the side of the chop to
your liking I mean it's pretty raw in
the center you like the flavor of it
though the honey Karen no way too sweet
I'm not satisfied with the quality the
food's coming out of the kitchen
I believe our chef has a learning curve
to be where he needs to be thank you
later oh [ __ ] oh god stay with me girl
knows a Apple risotto
wow what a pile of [ __ ] that sums up on
that plate there he's as good a chef as
either than keeper [ __ ] useless the
risotto was sweet with what's in there
apple juice apple concentrate sure
Apple concentrate in a risotto yes sir
come on it's about my menu chef so this
is all you're doing then oh my god it
can't possibly mess up a soft-boiled egg
what I'm just like going is this really
happening
he can't even born a [ __ ] egg [ __ ]
thing's still got feathers on it
[Music]
well you have here is the chocolate cake
it's white and dark chocolate
strawberries bacon it's like we've had a
crises with the toilet paper Department
someone's wipe their ass with my
daughter I mean it's just I've never
seen anything so [ __ ] unappetizing as
a dessert and all my life absolutely
bacon and chocolate pizza oMFG
yes you didn't like any of it not one
thing [ __ ]